george floyd is getting a geography
there's a new book coming out it's a
biography of george floyd talk about
people who don't need biographies uh
he's getting a biography published may
17 2022
this is going to be coming out from one
of the imprints of penguin random house
a very prestigious publishing house
here's the press release quote
the biography of george floyd shows the
athletic young boy raised in the
projects of houston's third ward who
would become a father
a partner a friend and a man constantly
in search of a better life
oh yeah is that is that so in
retracing floyd's story samuels and olo
renipa these are two washington post
reporters
bring to light the determination floyd
carried as he faced the relentless
struggle to survive as a black man in
america
now i'm going to translate that from the
delusional fantasy of penguin random
house into reality
george floyd was a career criminal who
robbed a pregnant woman at gunpoint and
never turned his life around ever and in
his final moments was only killed
because he was resisting arrest and
committing a crime at his very last
moments and was super duper high on
drugs had taken a lethal dose of drugs
never ever once improved his life
and was
for his entire career a menace to
society
and
did not have a constant struggle
to survive as a black man in america
made very very bad choices
i think that book
i think that book would be a lot more
honest if you wrote that about but i i
don't think that one would get published
i think instead
you have this fantasy this near what
this is about obviously this has nothing
to do with george floyd the book that
they're publishing it has to do with the
narrative
white people bad black people good
really easy for white people to live
very hard for black people to live
george floyd saint martyr
a hero a demigod
um
even if that story is false it gets to a
greater truth here's the narrative kyle
kyle rittenhouse evil white supremacist
terrorist
all the
pedophile rapist career criminal rioters
who were chasing him or good wonderful
saintly anti-racist protesters and even
if the reality isn't isn't that
even if that narrative is a lie
it gets to
a greater truth what it gets to
is a fantasy but it's a fantasy with a
lot of institutional backing
i'm so glad you liked that clip
i'm really it makes me feel very good
now if you want to get more clips like
that you've got to
ring the bell subscribe you'll get full
episodes of the show and if you want the
fully uncensored show and maybe you get
more notifications than our big tech
friends want to allow head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play
type in the michael knowles show th
t-h-e-space m-i-c-h-a-e-l-space
k-n-w-l-e-s space s-h-o-w
period
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five-star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you